france gall n'a de cesse de rendre
hommage au talent de michel berger
brutalement disparu l'été dernier
l'ancien groupe i du pianiste fait
encore mieux avec un disque qui est un
véritable exploit technique pour la
première fois au monde en 24 heures
seulement france vient de sortir ce
petit cd simple dans lequel elle reprend
deux des titres favoris de michel la
négresse blonde et surtout manuel chang
une performance dont ont été les témoins
gérard dalmas et jean-françois chevet
dire que hier encore à la même heure il
n'y avait rien france gall commençait à
peine l'enregistrement live du premier
cd commando du monde théâtre de paris
lieu fétiche de la grande famille michel
berger depuis starmania quelques
choristes prête voix forte
raphaël berger 12 ans leïla la nouvelle
voie jumelles
et puis re nous en sommes marc lavoine
20 heures rue blanche mixage immédiate
dans le fameux semi-remorque voyageurs
magnétophone numérique 48 pistes
aventure technique qui aurait plu à
michel berger c'était quelqu'un qui
n'était pas patient les choses aillent
vite
perfectionniste donc c'est souvent assez
difficile saleh 2 mais oui je pense à
lui à minuit chez diane studio parisien
spécialisé version définitive et départ
pour la mayenne maison mp au renommé
pour ses pressage jusqu'à 250 mille cd
par jours 4 heures 15 ce matin toujours
le marathon la banque devient matrice
dit la mère nickel technicité de haut
niveau et guerre à l'ennemi numéro un la
poussière midi aujourd'hui la boucle est
bouclée quelques heures pour faire ce
qui d'habitude demande dix jours la
groupie du pianiste a réussi son défi
bel hommage à son compositeur préféré
non